I'm a question that I think you know I
think it's fans most of us all of us so
hopefully realized that there have to be
changes between the books and the TV
show that would no it's good they're
going to be kind of different animals or
almost parallel you know parallel but
different stories one one thing that
kids come up quite a bit you know
discussions I've had with fans is that
the house of the undying in the season
finale you know there was not as much
there as obviously as in the books and
you know I guess from my mighty senses
that I to put everything in would have
probably blown the budget but you know
there seems to be a choice that the
creators or the Dan and David have made
that it's more about it an examination
of power and being powerful and
powerless and how you shift between
those worlds and there's less of the
kind of Mythology over thousands of
years is that something that we think is
you know an appropriate choice for the
show to make we remember much said about
the house of the undying stuff well this
is just a general question specific
question their idea I mean in a lot of
the material in the house of the undying
in the books is in the nature of
prophecy and also some glimpses into the
into the past and I can do that in the
books because I know you know roughly
when and where it's going to be paid off
i I you know you'd really have to talk
to David and Dan and get a precise
explanation why they made the choices
they made in in that particular scene
but I think so it maybe they were a
little leery of the prophecy for this we
don't know how many seasons we're gonna
have or how many hours you're gonna have
each season and you know would some of
these plot threads later on have to be I
don't have to be eliminated and if so it
would sort of be stupid our whole
prophecy of something that never pays
off down the road because we have to cut
that thread or cut that character or
something for
for budgetary reasons they they have
been not doing a lot with the the
prehistory the flashbacks the stuff that
occurred 16 years ago 20 years ago 300
years ago I mean there's some references
to it but not not a lot and sooner or
later they are going to have to deal
with
I think Rhaegar and Lyanna and what
happened between them and the Battle of
the Trident and and all of these things
and the Mad King I know for the first
season they did shoot some flashback
scenes with the with the Mad King but
they were never included in the final I
don't take so I don't know it's an
interesting question see how they've
been I'm kind of going to handle that
because certainly in the books the past
the present the future you know all
reflect upon each other and are included
part of it I mean this also gets into a
larger issue of exposition and and I
know that the critics of coin this
exposition term which has become widely
adopted and part of the discussion of
the show but if you even pushing aside
the sex part of sex position as to a
separate issue been discussed at some
point if we wish and just looking at the
exposition part there's a tremendous
amount of exposition in the books
exposition is easy to do in a novel I
can just have my character think about
oh we're passing the castle this castle
has been here for 400 years
it was originally get out of the Mad
Lord
Bertram lived there and he ate all of
his children
ominous even now but of course when
you're filming you have to put that in
the mouth of someone you had them write
a past and someone actually has to say
that unless you're going to do a
voiceover door that
so either you lose the exposition or you
have a lot of people kind of giving
historical lectures along the way or
talking about the deep dark secrets of
their own personal use and this is the
challenge you know as a novelist I have
many tools of bereted and exposition is
one of them expedition through internal
monologue exposition simply through
expository cruise I mean a paragraph
another in a book a paragraph of
expository prose is nothing you know you
read it and it's over and then you're
right onto the action you've hardly
noticed the speed bump in the road but
in a in a TV show it's a big thing where
suddenly somebody starts talking about
history for for a minute on screen a
minute on screen is a lot more than a
minutes worth of reading material in
that it's a very briefly one of the
reasons I'm so excited to be here is
when I was a kid 1980 I was reading
within science fiction walking into
walls and I grew up and put it aside and
did more serious things you seem like a
good idea at the time
and then last year yes I'm late to the
late to it I picked up a game of summon
to the next thing you know I'm walking
into walls again and the first time I
thirty years because I can't take my
nose out of the book and I'm curious as
to how you did this to me
about the book and about the books and
your skills and I want to see if I can
if I can get some tips from you because
I don't want to read historically
fantasies first about that why didn't
you start a game of Thrones with the
Baratheon rebelled because you know
everything about it why do you start
sixteen years after its events you know
I didn't know everything about it
actually I I sort of found out about it
as the characters dishes I went on and
so there's a lot of the process of
discovery in some ways I think that
particularly in the early books but the
process was still ongoing
I'm raining forwards and backwards at
the same time I'm revealing what's
happening in the the present of the book
and through devices like internal
monologue and exposition and and so
forth I'm also revealing what happened
sixteen years ago and the the process of
the revelation of what happened during
Robert's rebellion is is particularly
interesting I I think made more
interesting because I'm revealing it
through a series of point-of-view
characters who have a different
recollection of it you know I mean the
equivalent in real life terms is sitting
down and discussing the Vietnam period I
have a very sore memories of of the
Vietnam War from someone who was
cleaning for Dean McCarthy kind of guy
demonstrating here at Northwestern and
let us get out of Vietnam very different
perspective on the war did somebody like
to uphold the man who went to Vietnam
and that does that shot off or you know
various other people and work some
conservative who was all for the war and
all that I mean we all have these events
took place but what actually took place
where we're reflecting into the past and
I find that very interesting which is
another difference of course between the
television and books as a as a prose
writer I have the structure of a
viewpoint character but the camera is an
object
view point we when we present the
flashback we're saying this is exactly
how it happened we can't necessarily do
a rock full-on Rashomon kind of thing
where we present several versions as
they've seen the whole idea of
subjectivity and different people
remembering events in different ways
having different interpretations of
claims that happen is very difficult I
just to follow on from what Peter was
asking about I think one of the things
you do so well by having that type focus
on each person is explore you know I
just want to kind of get back to the
idea of power that that I was talking
about earlier that I think one of the
things that's so involving about the
stories is that the people who start out
with power might be quite limited in
some day ways you can lose power and
that ups the stakes and the people who
are allegedly powerless with the right
kind of cunning and guile and smarts and
you know even Hart they can find ways
out of you know situations that seem
hopeless is that without a sort of an
idea that was in the back of your mind
and you set out to start to do this to
some examine those ideas about power and
hierarchy and how those things aren't as
fixed as people might think that they
are that'll subject of power is is
fascinating to me
you know both now historical context and
then in their real context I mean how do
they how about how does the power of
work what's it based on I embarrasses
riddle which I was very glad that they
included I think is one of the most
important parts of the book where ETS
theory and I know who has the real panel
in that situation where the the rich man
and the priest and the King are each
telling telling the sword to kill the
other people it's actually the some sort
of lapse of power in a sense he's the
one who has a sword in his hand he has
the power of life and death over the
other three but he is I'm going to obey
one of the other three because of some
illusion of power and yet these are you
know I mean when I see that scene played
out in my mind's eye these are like
three old fat guys and you know the
south sword none of them can actually do
anything themselves for a self sword and
yet they command
somehow because they can summon other
other sellswords well why do those
ownself swords obey I mean this whole
notion of what however is is is our
societies have built on on this
structure of sand wall societies and
yeah and you see that periodically with
the Falls of great empires and nations
you know what the Soviet Union you know
and it was looked solid and eternal this
gigantic pleased States and one day it
just blew away we're not gonna follow
those guys anymore let's get rid of them
and we'll bring in some good guys and
suddenly the Soviet Union was gone
overnight why does that happen I was
reading a book a couple months ago a
popular history of Jerusalem fascinated
by old history of Jerusalem from you
know biblical read history and the
Maccabees and the Jewish state military
to modern-day Jerusalem it fascinating
history of them in Jerusalem has been
through so many different things the
Crusaders and the the Turks and the
Arabs and and the Jewish empires early
on the Romans everybody said Jerusalem
at some point and then usually they've
murdered a lot of other people but I was
reading about this one particular crazy
Sultan or Holly for something good their
Islamic thing it was clearly nuts and
one point he decided his doctors were
trying to kill him so he had all of his
doctors killed okay men it will reform
and it's a most primitive but then he
decided that the women of the women of
the court were conspiring against him
but he liked women goes they had like
babies and other uses sexually and stuff
like that so I didn't want to have them
all killed so he commanded his guard to
cut off the hands of all of the women in
the court I don't need like his own
wives and concubines but evidently their
wives and concubines as well
and they did it and you know huge drama
comes out of that and don't be surprised
if sometime in Ice and Fire I have some
crazy King I mean that's where you know
you read enough history and boy it's all
just there you know the people that used
my books or the TV show being you know
exceptionally bloody and obviously think
they're never about the real Middle Ages
the history at Jerusalem or some of the
things that actually happened in real
life I mean there's a link Disneyland
some of the things that really happen I
think that's the first comparison
Disneyland to Westeros theme park people